this used to be fertile farmland but
last year alone the village kamitani
bambara lost 25 hectares of land that
was all because of salinization as the
village chief madhu to ray explains
jamaican allah will come a time bomb but
i'm a freaking a Joey see if things go
on like this the future will be very
difficult we're worried this Alan
ization will reach the entire village
will forget acted with the coop don't we
know if you live in a village that's
been completely taken over by salt life
there will be unimaginable on little
money clean ha no monitoring jeopardy
for you el hadj ballet CA from the
International Union for Conservation of
Nature says many villages in Senegal
seen as salaam delta are under threat
saltwater from the atlantic ocean is
pushing unchecked into the delta
the forest that constitutes a barrier
between the coast and agricultural land
is disappearing because of the excessive
clear cutting of trees for there would
say a is working on a protection project
in six villages as here in pege life is
lived according to traditional rules so
that villagers can continue to live here
the salinization must be stopped to
protect further farmland the inhabitants
are building small dams called diggit
the technology is simple and cheap
though it's not yet known how much
effect it will have in addition new
trees are being planted they help
improve the fields by protecting the
soil from wind erosion but protecting
the environment brings conflicts of
interest unlimited use of resources such
as water and wood is no longer possible
farmers livestock breeders and fishermen
have to come to agreement say yes says
guidelines are planned it was a spittle
Buddhist approaches we hope at the end
of this process to have a document which
contains consensual rules for all the
parties to permit them to improve the
sustainable management of natural
resources in the area it would be an
important step towards giving the next
generation of future in pitch